comment on serait en vente comment on
garantit en générations futures de la
vie et de l'emploi sur sur ces stations
et dans un village de montagne comme La
Clusaz
depuis deux ans à La Clusaz on a mis en
place un travail de fond une réflexion
sur cette vision qu'on devait avoir en
2050 pour nous permettre à la fois de
consolider le produit ski sur le secteur
ou les secteurs où il y a le plus de
neige et en même temps mettre en place
progressivement sur les décennies à
venir des activités qui ne vont nous
permettre d'être moins dépendants à la
neige et qui vont nous permettre de nous
adapter à ce changement climatique et
faire évoluer cette économie touristique
et garantir l'emploi et l'économie
localement
[Musique]
pour assurer la réussite de ce nouveau
modèle on doit consolider on doit
permettre à cette économie du ski de
vivre encore un petit peu et donc il
faut qu'on arrive à la à la sécuriser il
faut qu'on arrive à tenir le plus
longtemps possible du ski pour financer
la diversification et la transition
[Musique]
c'est vrai que dans notre boutique on
propose les visites de la distillerie il
y a une petite partie vidéo une petite
partie de dégustation en moyenne les
gens restent minimum 30 minutes dans
notre boutique donc ça fait déjà une
petite activité et puis pourquoi pas
c'est un projet on aimerait bien avec
mon frère faire peut-être un jour le
musée du génépi dans La Clusaz
[Musique]